MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Veer.
VEER MUCHANDI: Hello, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you are
an App Modernization Solution
Manager at Google, right?
And you have an app for
us to modernize today?
VEER MUCHANDI: Yes, we have
a Legacy two-tier Node.js
application running on a VM.
And we want to modernize it
using serverless technologies.
The VM is costing
us money 24 by 7.
Also, we have to assign someone
with the right operation skills
to maintain it.
We'd like Google
to do that for us.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
And does the team running
this app know containers?
VEER MUCHANDI: The team has
started the containerization
journey.
They considered Kubernetes,
but they don't have
enough experience with that.
MARTIN OMANDER: A
lot of organizations
are in that place.
Let's migrate the
app for them using
Cloud Run, which doesn't require
them to learn Kubernetes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VEER MUCHANDI: This is
what the app UI looks like.
It's a simple to-do
list application.
Let me add a couple
of to-do list items
about modernizing
this application.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
What does the
architecture look like?
VEER MUCHANDI: Here
it is, a web frontend,
and Node.js backend,
and a MongoDB database.
The HTML and JavaScript
for web frontend
is served by the
Node.js backend.
MARTIN OMANDER: Does the
app use server-side sessions
or any other storage
outside the database?
VEER MUCHANDI: No.
It's a simple app where all
the users see the same content.
All the data is in the database.
Let's keep the
database as is for now.
We'll move the Node.js backend
and the serving of HTML
to Cloud Run, then we
can shut down that VM.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That makes sense.
Let's look at the database
machine for a minute.
VEER MUCHANDI: We need
to set up a serverless VP
connector from Cloud
Run to this database.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Let me click the Serverless
VPC connector option here.
And then I'll create one.
I'll give it a name, and I'll
use all the default settings.
And now let's create it.
This will take a
minute, so let's get
started on the next step.
VEER MUCHANDI: Let's have a
look at the source code here.
This is a Git repo,
which is good.
Most of the enterprises
want their code protected,
especially when the development
is done offshore or remotely.
Think COVID, right?
I'm going to use a browser,
browser-based editor that
works like VS Code but doesn't
depend on my workstation.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good idea.
Editing the code in the
cloud also means that it
doesn't matter what
version of Node.js--
NPM, et cetera-- that you
or I have on our laptops.
VEER MUCHANDI: Right.
First, I'll open the
Google Cloud shell here,
which gives me a command
line in the cloud.
Now that I have
a command line, I
can run a Git
clone of this repo.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
And then you'll edit
it in the cloud?
VEER MUCHANDI: Yeah, I'll click
here to start the cloud editor.
This editor looks
and feels similar
to a traditional editor, like
VS code running on my laptop,
but it runs in the cloud.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
The Cloud Run docs
say that our code
should listen on a port
defined by the port environment
variable?
VEER MUCHANDI: Yeah.
Here it is.
It looks like the
existing code already
does that so we don't
have to change anything.
If the port had been hardcoded
here, we have to change it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
How does the code connect
to the database, Veer?
VEER MUCHANDI: Well, let's see.
It looks like it reads
the connection parameters
from the environment
variables, as well.
Whoever wrote this application
knew what they were doing.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, well done.
Veer, do you think we
should write a Docker file
and build a container
ourselves for this app?
VEER MUCHANDI: Well, we could.
It's not very hard.
But the team isn't very
comfortable with containers
yet.
So let's deploy from source
code and use Buildpacks instead.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that makes sense.
It's a Node app so we should
probably run NPM install first.
VEER MUCHANDI: OK,
I'm doing so now.
Now that all the packages
have been installed,
I will prep the gcloud
run deploy command.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
We need to tell Cloud Run
about the VPC connector
and the environment variables.
VEER MUCHANDI: Absolutely.
We can also set all that
in Google Cloud console,
but the team wants things
done from the command line
so they can automate it later.
Here is the gcloud run command
with all the environment
variables, with database
connection parameters.
I'm also adding
the VPC connector.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm, very nice.
VEER MUCHANDI: Let's run it.
It's asking me a few
follow-up questions here
about region and such.
I'll answer them.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
It looks like the
build is running.
Let me open the build log
here in the Cloud Console.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, it looks like
things are happening here.
The Buildpack is
taking our source code
and building a container
from it without us
having to create a Docker
file or know anything
about containers.
That makes it easy
for developers.
VEER MUCHANDI: It looks
like the build is done now.
Look at the container
is replaced.
MARTIN OMANDER: Uh-huh.
Ah, there is our container.
VEER MUCHANDI: Now let's go to
the Cloud Run in the Console.
MARTIN OMANDER: Let's see.
Yeah, there's our
deployed service.
The URL is shown here.
Let's hit it.
VEER MUCHANDI:
Hmm, look at that.
The app is working.
And we are seeing the same
to-do list items in the UI
as before, when this app was
running in the virtual machine.
And now I can mark these
two to-do list items
that I created before as done.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
That reminds me, we don't
really need that virtual machine
anymore, do we?
VEER MUCHANDI: We don't.
Let's turn it off.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
I'm navigating to
Virtual Machines.
There it is, and
I'm deleting it.
VEER MUCHANDI: Feels
good, doesn't it?
We moved code from
a virtual machine
that was costing us money
24 by 7 to Cloud Run
where we pay for
CPU and memory usage
only when the request
is being served.
If we get less traffic
at night, we pay less.
And if we get no
traffic on weekends,
we don't pay anything at all.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
And even if the container
is ready to serve requests,
we don't pay anything until
an actual request comes in.
Also, we do not have
to assign anyone
to maintain the virtual machine.
Veer, will the team build
new versions of this web app?
VEER MUCHANDI: Yeah,
I think they probably
will need a CI/CD
pipeline for that,
but that will be a
story for another day.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Sounds good to me.
Thank you for
watching, everyone.
If you have any
questions for Veer or me,
let us know in the comments.
Also, let us know what you
thought of today's episode
and other serverless
topics you'd
like to see in the future.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]